big story is uh last night harry and
megan
uh gave their big interview to oprah
everybody's talking about that like yeah
apparently like 17 million people saw it
yeah yeah a lot of people watched well
guess what the royal family
is retaliating now as we told you queen
elizabeth and prince charles have their
own podcast
yeah we uh played you a little bit of
that last week
well they just released another episode
this morning
to fire back welcome to fiddlesticks
i'm your host queen elizabeth and i'm
prince charles
you're mad received did you see last
night's broadcast on american television
i did it was shocking the court will
never be the same
it won't is majesty the king reigns
supreme
king james king james at the nba
all-star game
charles i've never seen so many dunks
your majesty i'm not talking about
baseball i'm talking about the interview
with megan and harry oh that
yes it was devastating your majesty we
need to do immediate
damage control correction you
need to do damage control charles megan
said and i quote
the queen was always wonderful to me
here we go and harry and i zoom all the
time
in fact he helped me put on the cat
filter i love it
your majesty everyone is speculating
that i made those awful comments about
skin
color well did we
i admit it sounds like something i'd say
but
it also could have been our footman
who's a spaniard
people are saying that the royal family
has been harder on meghan markle
than we were on prince andrew who prince
andrew
your son my brother he's been accused of
pedophilia what are you talking about i
don't have a sound called prince andrew
i have three children you edward and
anne
ma'am you have four children charles
i'm looking at a family photo right now
there's you me edward princess anne
and your father on the end of the couch
your majesty
prince andrew's there his head is
covered with a square space
what a segway charles if you're looking
to build a new website
squarespace offers modern templates
and scalable e-commerce solutions
go to squarespace promo code
i have just three children for 20
off
you